-Pro-Trump election deniers
have won GOP primaries
across the country,
which could put them
in positions of power
in swing states during
the next presidential election.
Meanwhile, a key Trump
White House official
has been subpoenaed
by a federal grand jury
as the Justice Department
investigates the events
surrounding the coup attempt
on January 6th.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's never been more important
than it is right now
to investigate
and hold accountable the people
who nearly toppled our democracy
on January 6th,
because, as we have said
many times on this show,
they came very close, and they
will absolutely do it again
if they get the chance.
Trump is already in the process
of setting up
another coup attempt
by attempting to put loyalists
in positions of power
across the country.
-Former President Trump's
influence
is being put to the test,
endorsing several
so-called election deniers,
Republican candidates
who support his false claims
of a stolen election.
-Tonight's primaries testing
former President Trump's power
over the Republican Party
and nowhere more so
than here in Arizona,
a state Trump lost
and where he has now waged
an all-out assault
on the GOP establishment
that refused to go along
with his false election claims.
Up and down the ballot,
Trump-endorsed candidates
who deny the legitimacy
of the 2020 election.
Arizona is a revenge state
for Trump.
He's endorsed candidates
from the U.S. Senate
all the way down
to the state legislature
and even the secretary of state,
who would oversee the next
presidential election.
-I'm sorry. Arizona is
a revenge state for him?
What's he going to do,
make us live there?
Oh, sure,
it's sunny and beautiful,
but just try to order a pizza
after 9:00 p.m.
Speak of the sun,
make sure you find
a dermatologist you really like,
because you're going to see
her more
than you see your own family.
Our head writer is from Arizona,
and he obviously
has some issues.
[ Laughter ]
Nothing says divider
instead of uniter
more than a former president
with a revenge state.
You lost an election.
Stop acting like Liam Neeson
threatening to get
his daughter back.
"I have a very particular
set of skills.
I can shank a golf ball
90 yards.
I can drink three Diet Cokes
in one sitting, and that's it.
So in the end, the end,
it's just the two skills.
And as I say them out loud,
I'm not sure how either
is going to help me
get my daughter back.
So this -- this might be
one of those occasions
where you just drop her off
back at the house.
Would that work?"
[ Dial tone ]
"Hello? Hello?
Good news, Don Jr.
You're my new favorite."
"You're still number four, Eric.
I don't want to
have to explain it."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, why does Donald Trump
have a revenge state?
Is this the first time
a former president
has gone on a, quote, revenge
tour after leaving office?
Like, usually, ex-presidents
retire to a quiet life
of paid speaking gigs
and celebrity golf tournaments.
I don't remember William Howard
Taft going from town to town
looking for anyone
who didn't vote for him in 1912
so he could kick them
in the [bleep]
"Hey, you with
the Woodrow Wilson button,
I'm going to fight you.
I just need to squeeze
out of this bathtub first."
By the way, Taft never got stuck
in the White House bathtub.
That's just a myth you learned
in middle school
for some reason.
What a bummer to climb to
the heights of the presidency,
the most powerful position
in the world,
and all anyone remembers
about you is a rumor
some jerk made up about you
getting stuck in a bathtub.
That would be like if, instead
of remembering Albert Einstein
for his theory of relativity,
all anyone knew about him
was that one time he [bleep]
his pants at a Panera Bread.
And that was today's
dubious product placement
for Panera Bread.
So Trump is on a revenge tour,
crisscrossing the country
to back candidates
who, if they get into office,
will help him
steal the election again
in 2024,
because he has all but declared
that he's running again.
He keeps dropping
not-so-subtle hints,
including at his golf course
in New Jersey last week.
-Mr. President, are you planning
to announce soon for the --
-Oh, you're gonna be so happy.
-Oof. What was that low,
gravelly voice?
If someone came up to me
on a golf course
looking like that, hunched over,
all hoarse and sweaty and said,
"You're gonna be so happy,"
I would assume he was selling
discount golf balls
he found in the woods.
"Got a perfectly good Titleist.
Also, you want to see
a dead squirrel?
I can show it to you.
You want to see a dead squirrel?
A bird ate its eyes.
Come on, dead squirrel?"
So Trump is very much set on
trying the coup again in 2024.
And even if he doesn't run,
or if he loses the GOP primary
to someone else,
the loyalists
and election deniers
he's trying to put in place will
undoubtedly use their power,
if they win in November,
to prevent any Democrat
from winning
an election ever again.
And now that they've won
their GOP primaries,
these pro-Trump election deniers
are just one more step away
from taking key positions
of power
in swing states
all across the country.
In Arizona, for example, a slate
of pro-Trump election deniers
have either already won
or are currently leading
in GOP primaries
for federal and state offices,
including governor.
Kari Lake,
the candidate currently leading
the GOP primary for governor,
has said
some truly insane [bleep]
about the 2020 election.
-Anybody who was involved
in that corrupt, shady,
shoddy election of 2020,
lock them up.
I refuse to stop
talking about it
until our elected officials
stand up and do something.
We want people to be arrested,
prosecuted, and thrown in jail.
We have this illegitimate
President Biden
who's allowing it to happen.
But the fake news
wants us to think
that that guy got
81 million votes.
[ Crowd booing ]
Okay.
-I love how Trump supporters
keep insisting it's impossible
that Joe Biden
got 81 million votes.
You know how he got
that many votes --
by running against Donald Trump.
Okay?
It's like if you told me --
if you told me
the Warriors scored 160 points,
I might also be suspicious
until you told me
they were playing the Knicks,
and then, you know...
And, look, you guys, I know
basketball isn't in season,
but we're in a bit of a jam
here at "Late Night,"
because our summertime
whipping boys, the Mets,
are currently in first place.
And if I've -- Yeah.
[ Applause ]
And if I've learned anything
from my time in New York,
it's that if the Mets are
in first place on August 4th,
they're on lock to win
the World Series.
The other day, a member
of my crew said to me,
"Hey, we're 3 1/2 up,
with only 58 games to play."
And all I could say was,
"Why do you keep
letting yourself get hurt?"
But here's what's truly ironic
and revealing
about Kari Lake's lead
in the Arizona GOP primary.
She was actually trailing
on Tuesday night
before more votes were counted
and put her over the top
by Wednesday morning,
the exact kind of thing
election deniers
would lose their [bleep] over
if it was the other side.
Remember when Trump
kept complaining over and over
about what he claimed
were mysterious ballot dumps
supposedly putting Biden
in the lead overnight?
That's just normal vote
counting. That's how it works.
But Trump thought
it was suspicious.
-This election was over,
and then they did dumps.
They call them dumps,
big, massive dumps.
In Michigan and Pennsylvania
and all over.
-You guys remember that?
You remember the leader
of the free world
complaining about big,
massive dumps,
like -- like he's working
in the elephant enclosure
at the Bronx Zoo?
"Oh, Goddamn it. Who let
the elephants eat cheesecake?
It's going to take me days
to clean up."
You know how --
You know how when you go
to a presidential library,
they usually have
an interactive section
where you can press a button
and hear some original audio,
like one of FDR's fireside chats
or JFK's inaugural speech?
I don't think Trump deserves
a presidential library,
but if he gets one,
I hope the interactive feature
is a toilet that uses his voice
whenever you flush.
-Welcome to the Donald J. Trump
Presidential Library.
Flush the handle to begin
your journey through history.
[ Toilet flushes ]
-They did dumps.
They call them dumps,
big, massive dumps.
-So now --
So now, all of a sudden --
all of a sudden,
big, massive dumps
that change the race overnight
are totally cool,
as long as they benefit
the pro-Trump candidates,
which just shows you
that it's all [bleep]
a fabricated pretext
designed to justify
whatever outcome they want.
And that is why we need to
root these people out now
before they get into positions
that would give them power
over our elections in 2024.
Arguably an even scarier example
is the GOP's nominee
for secretary of state
in Arizona,
a position
that directly supervises
the state's elections.
-Election denialism is still
coursing through the veins
of this Republican Party.
No better example
than in Arizona.
The results of last night's
elections make clear
for secretary of state,
for example, Mark Finchem.
He is a Republican legislator
in Arizona,
one of the leading voices
in denying
the results of the 2020 election
that Joe Biden
won the state of Arizona.
He is going to be
the Republican nominee
for the secretary of state,
the top election official.
-Trump's candidate,
Mark Finchem,
who acknowledged having ties
to the Oath Keepers
and was in Washington
on January 6th.
-This is insane. We can't let
a guy who wanted to overthrow
the last election
oversee future elections.
I wouldn't keep using Wally
as my cue card guy
if he started undermining me
by writing stuff
I didn't approve of,
like, "Wally is the best.
He's the most popular.
He should host this show."
Wait a second.
[ Laughter ]
Damn it!
Wally!
I'd be mad, but what can I say?
I agree with you.
You would be a better host.
Wait!
Just stop it!
[ Applause ]
The point is we need to
stop these people now,
which is why it is encouraging
to see the Justice Department
stepping up its investigation
of the coup attempt.
They're reportedly
asking witnesses about Trump
as part of their investigation.
And now a federal grand jury
has subpoenaed
a senior
Trump White House official
who was a key witness
to the events
that led up to January 6th.
-Now, it's a dramatic
development in the January 6th
investigation.
A source tells CNN
former Trump White House Counsel
Pat Cipollone
has been subpoenaed
by a federal grand jury
investigating efforts
to overturn the 2020 election.
He's considered part of
Donald Trump's inner circle,
and the move to subpoena him
signals an aggressive step
by the Justice Department.
It shows investigators
are looking at conduct
directly related to Trump,
as well as his closest allies,
efforts to overturn
his election defeat.
-The subpoena is part of
the federal investigation
into the January 6th assault
on the Capitol
and efforts to overturn
the 2020 election.
Although it is not clear exactly
which grand jury called him.
There are currently
two known grand juries,
one looking at the scheme
to assemble fake electors
and the other focused
specifically
on the events of January 6th.
-Oof, that is bad news
for Trump.
When he heard that,
he probably took a few...
-Big, massive dumps.
-In his pants.
Also, it's not a good sign
when you get subpoenaed
by a grand jury and you don't
even know which grand jury.
Like, most people,
if you got called
to a federal grand jury,
you'd be like, "Um,
I know what this is about."
But these guys are like,
"I am sorry.
Can you be more specific?
I'm under a lot
of investigations right now."
The GOP's slow-moving coup
is still happening as we speak.
If election deniers win races
in swing states like Arizona,
Michigan, and Pennsylvania,
they will absolutely
use their power
to ensure that no Democrat
can win an election
in those states ever again.
It's not about
election integrity,
it's about power,
as we've seen in Arizona
just this week.
They don't even believe
their own lies.
If overnight vote-counting
helps them, it's legit.
But if it hurts them, then it's
somehow evidence of fraud.
The amount of [bleep]
they've been churning out
to justify their lies
is equivalent to...
-81 million...
-Big, massive dumps.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
That was "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.